[Music]
thank you everybody
thank you tedious um yeah we're going to
talk about web accessibility especially
specifically testing and how to find
accessibility issues um but again let me
introduce myself my name is adrian i'm
from spain
i work as an accessibility software
engineer at github
where i try to advocate for the
accessibility principles especially in
development and you can find me almost
everywhere under my surname
so accessibility and
probably the first question that i got
always asked is what is this a11y that
we always see how many people knows what
a11y is
good um this is because there's 11
letters between the a and the y in the
word accessibility the same as i 18n in
internationalization
so you're going to see this a lot now so
you know what that means
why is so obvious in the real world that
those four situations are completely
wrong right in the first situation we
and they have two first situations we
see a very steep ramp in this third
situation we see a ramp at the end there
are stairs and the fourth situation is a
completely useless one
let me put you another example
someone arrives with a wheelchair
there's an accessible button super good
the doors open automatically surprise
yes
there are
stairs at the end
so why is it it seems obvious that
either the one who implemented this is
not disabled or the testing phase of
those products were not done correctly
so it is so obvious in the real world
but when we move to the online world
it's not that obvious that a website is
accessible accessible or not so when we
talk about web accessibility we talk
about web tools websites technologies
that are designed for everyone to be
used not to exclude anyone
let me put you an example of of this you
go to your favorite online
e-commerce app let's call it jungle
amazon was taken
so you want to see your latest purchases
and you call the support team and then
they can tell you something oh you need
to click in the button in the top right
corner or you want to change your email
address and you don't find where it is
so they can tell you oh you need to
click in the button with the engine icon
but for someone who is blind
there's no such a button who looks like
an engine icon or there's no such a top
right corner they don't use a mouse for
that so we need to have this in mind
when we develop our applications
it it might be that we
wrongly associate web accessibility
only with visually impaired people but
there are other types of impairments
we have touch hear c or speak
impairments and we can
categorize it as permanent temporary or
situational so in the case of visually
impaired people we can see that
permanent is someone who is blind
temporary someone with a eye injured
like a cataract or maybe a distracted
driver you're driving you look for to
talk to the
co-pilot then you are disabled towards
this the the road
but it's true that i'm going to focus on
visually impaired people um
a bit of small numbers in 2021 we were
around 7.9 billion people
and more than 2.2 billion people are
visually impaired or any kind blind
colorblind protanopia
uses glasses blurry vision any kind of
visual impair so when we develop when we
we create our online businesses we want
to reach as much people as possible and
those are our users as well
okay let's talk about testing now
um
testing is is awesome automate tests are
super cool they can free up your qa team
to for manually testing everything but
they're not magic
because only from 20 to 50 i always say
20 to 50 but it's more 20 to 30 percent
of the accessibility issues can be found
with automate tests
and we need to include this automate
test in a larger
phase of testing where manual tests are
as important as automate tests
so i'm going to tell you a bit of what
works for me every day or what has
worked for me during those years every
day and
i'm gonna pass from code to uh browser
terminal and i'm gonna end up with
manual tests so the first thing that i
that i can tell you is test your code
while you develop
we can use
tools that
shows us the issues in the browser or we
can test in directly in the code editor
so the first tool that i want to show
you is axe
axe is a accessibility engine built by
dq
and they provide a react library they
someone did a view library and for those
who develop in angular you can use
directly the protractor with the
webdriver.js that axe provides so let's
see how it works
you need to install it as a developer
dependency in your application and
you have to be sure that you only import
and use this library in an environment
that is not in a production environment
so you don't have you don't want to
publicly expose those vulnerabilities
what is this tool doing well the tool is
um
exposing those vulnerabilities in the
console log of your
developer tools in the browser and what
we can see here is which element of your
html is is provoking the issue
what is the issue uh we have the
severity level from minor moderate
serial so we can see
if if we need to act immediately or we
can create an issue and work a bit later
or put it in the backlog
and it is grouped by appearances so if
you have the same error multiple times
then it's grouped
we have eslint so
if you use linters you can have the
plugin for the accessibility rules you
just need to include the plugin okay
install as a developer dependency again
you need to in include the plugin
and you need to extend
the rules for the recommended
accessibility rules that means that when
you go to the code editor in this call
in this case i'm using vs code
uh you can see this underline red wavy
and this is telling the linter is
telling you that in this line there's
something wrong you hover and then you
have the pop-up with what is the error
so those are the two things that you
there are multiple other tools but those
are uh two tools that you can start
using now to test while your code
and of course the linter you can use as
well you can see the issues as well in
the terminal
if you're testing a
design system or a component library and
you use storybook which is an amazing
library
i wrote an article about how to test the
accessibility of the components in a
more isolated environment like storybook
use the development tools of the browser
now we move to the browser and
well the browsers now come with a lot
and good tools uh specif i'm gonna show
you chromium either edge or chrome and
firefox so the first one that i wanted
you to show you is the color picker so
when you inspect a text element let's
say a button with a text element inside
then you have the css color
uh in the in the uh styles tab if you
click in the there's a small square with
the color if you click in the color you
you get the color picker
and there's a top and set color
contrast radio this contrast radio is
the radio between the color of the text
and the color of the background where
the test is okay it's located so the
text is in the button you can see that
the
color contrast between those two are not
passing either the double a or the
triple a contrast radio test those are
values that the w3c which is the
organization which sets the standards of
html css and javascript
sets
levels
for accessibility
you have the same in firefox so you can
use it in both
the accessibility tab as well in
chromium is very it's very good you can
see the whole accessibility tree so you
can see the accessibility name
of an element so
in the computer properties you can see
the order of the computational name so
we can see that the title is the less
important thing than the content for
example an anchor link so the content of
the anchor is more important than an
area label and the area labeled by is
the most important thing so if there's
an eleval buy and add a label are they
labeled by wins so this is the order of
the computational the accessible name
the same as we see in firefox
write your own unit test because here
all of you write your own unit test
right
yeah good
so
axe
has an extension or yest as a library
someone made a library
to use yes yes is in a testing library
for javascript
so we install it's a developer
dependency as well and what we are doing
here is to
write a test
with react dom server and what i'm doing
is transforming my whole application
into a string
this string i'm throwing it to the ax
engine and of course i expect to have no
violations in the test
so when i run my test in the terminal
i'm gonna see
those issues the same as i see i still
with the chrome
react act so we see what is the error
uh which element is causing the error
and a good thing that i think i forgot
to mention there's a direct link to
dquniversity.com
this is the official documentation from
dqe that they put for every issue so you
can learn more about
how to fix it and most importantly how
to not do it again
good so we move from code to browser now
we move into the terminal
and another tip is using cli tools so
command line interface tool to run
accessibility tests
of course we are back to axe family they
develop a cli tool
you need to install it globally in your
machine this time it's not a project
base is it global
in your machine and of course you can
run it just simply acts followed by the
url that you're testing in this case i'm
testing stack overflow
um
and we can see that it runs in a
headless chrome instance and we can see
pretty much the same results what are
the what is the issue which element is
provoking the issue and the direct link
to the eq university another similar
similar
tool is pa11y
same we install it globally and then we
use it exactly the same p11y followed by
the url that we want to test
we see pretty much the same results
right we see which is there or which
element is causing the errors in this
case we don't have a link
to any documentation is you
who needs to go to google and find a way
to fix this issue but we have something
very important here which is the
principle of the wakago the wcig which
are the guidelines that we are violating
so you can take this one google it and
then you have the solution
of course you don't have to to
deploy anything in any url you can test
it over localhost but maybe you have a
ton of urls to test so p11y has a ci so
is an extension of the library who's
going to look for a config file in your
in the root folder of your project and
you can specify an array of urls
what is it gonna do here we can perform
actions we can click in elements we can
wait for an element with an id or with a
class to load in the screen we can take
screenshots
so
he's identifying the three urls it's
taking the test pretty much the same
results and in the root folder of our
application we can see those screenshots
we can use it for reporting purposes or
if we have a visual regression test
tool we can use it there as well so it's
very
very useful
another tool is lighthouse lighthouse is
a library developed by google
and is included in every chrome browser
but we can use it in the cli
so same procedure we install it globally
and then we use it lighthouse followed
by the url
now i'm using minus minus view to launch
the report after that but instead of a
headless browser we are going to see a
full instance of chrome and we're going
to see a lot of tests performance
accessibility
low internet uh no internet um we see a
lot and at the end we're gonna see a
report
i think you are familiar with this
we click on accessibility and we can see
in a more graphic way again the issues
which issue what element is causing
then we have a link to the google
official documentation where we can find
more about this
but those are all
those
all are
pretty much the same behavior in the
terminal
what can we do with those cli tools
well if you have your code hosted in
github we can use github actions to
automate those accessibility tests
in your repository
github actions are just
workflows who execute
tasks
on demand
whatever you tell
the github action to run so
they are jaml files so and you need to
uh you need to place them in the github
workflows folder and what i did is
creating one github action for each cli
tool plus the unit test so i have one
for unit test one for x one for pa 11y
and one from lighthouse and what i'm
doing is i want every github action to
run every time that someone pushed to my
main branch
or someone who makes a pull request to
my main branch
every time that someone makes a pull
request we can see
those checks at the bottom of the pull
request
we can see if they succeed or they
failed
and of course we can click in details
and see more about it so i'm clicking in
details in the unit test because it has
a red cross that means it failed
and i can see the terminal where those
tests were run
and i can see that
there are issues in this in this
poor request about accessibility so i
need to to fix them before clicking in
merge
those are the issues and i can see them
and then i can again learn more about it
and try to fix it
but if you see there's one specific
tech that is green and it's not red
this is because lighthouse is not a
testing library it's a reporting library
so lighthouse that means that light has
successfully generated the report and is
you who need to read the report and act
accordingly with the report so you need
to evaluate what is wrong with your
website
and for lighthouse
the report that we already seen
it is generated publicly so it's going
to give you a public url
if you want to run this into a private
repo or your company wants to do it in a
private way you need to have your
lighthouse report server running
if not
then the url
looks like storage.googleapis.com
and it's going to be public it's not
going to be
accessible by anyone who doesn't know
the url but you need to know that it's
public
if you want to
see those actions in place they are in
this repository there's only one pull
request
it's not true there are two pull
requests but one
i made a mistake so forget about that
and if you want to read more about this
i wrote an article about this um
about how to make the pull request
disable the merge button until the
github actions are
all green
so with this one you
avoid putting an access inaccessible
code in production or at least in your
main branch then it's up to you your ci
cd
behavior
good we talked about before that only
between 20 30 of the out accessibility
issues can be found with automate tests
which
means that we need to include automate
tests in a more in a longer way in a
longer process where manual tests are
important and if we talk about manual
tests or simulation tests we need to
talk about screen readers
screen readers are software programs
that allows
blind or visually impaired people
to read what it is in this screen they
identify what is in the screen and is
with a synthetizer is read to the user
every operating system has their own
screen reader built in
apple either for ios or mac has voice
over windows has narrator
linux has orca and android has stockpack
there are other
commercial screening like nvda or yoss
but i'm not going to talk about screen
readers because if not then it will be
like two hours long
but i'm going to talk about
extensions in the browser
uh i know it said chrom's tension but
every extension that you see here is for
firefox as well
so the first one is axe again
uh dq made a very very good job here
you can find it this extension you can
find it under the developer tools in
your in in your browser
and you just need to click in analyze
then it's going to perform a whole
test
and what we are going to see here is
exactly the same as we saw in react x or
in the ax cli in the terminal with a
more visual thing right um we can see
which is the what is the problem which
element is causing the problem we can
read a bit more about the issue and we
can see this learn more which is the
link to dq university to learn more
about this
another very similar
extension is arc toolkit you can find
that as well under the development tools
and you just need to click in
test run tests there are a lot of
families of elements and clicking in
images
and what i can see here is
some images doesn't have i don't have
alternate text
i can click in the image and then i go
directly to the to the html element and
in the window they are going to be
highlighted so i can see they're very
very good which images doesn't have an
alternate test
accessibility insights is another very
good extension is developed by microsoft
and in this case i'm going to show you
one feature that this tool has
the top order or your website is very
important and it has to be consistent
with the content of your website because
visually impaired people or
meet visually impaired people normally
don't use a mouse use a keyboard to
navigate through your website
specifically the top key so they are
going to tap between um
interactive elements either buttons
links forms to navigate through your
website so if the top order of your
website is not consistent with the
content it's jumping around then it's
going to be a mess so with this tool
what we can do is a map of those top
order
so once it is is enabled then you can
start tabbing and it's going to make a
map with numbers of the top order and if
you can see if you see that this is the
correct order consistent with the
content well then it's good if not then
maybe you need to change the the
structure the dom structure the order of
the dom structure maybe you have an
element
float right if someone still use floats
and
and then you want the tabbing is is
incorrect then maybe you can fix it
as well you can take a screenshot maybe
for reporting purposes or maybe to have
a history of your
of your tab order
wave web is another extension that is
very very complete you can find it in
the in the extension tab um extension
bar and once you click boom as full test
is done you can see missing alternative
text and images you can see the order of
heading levels h1 h2 s3 which is very
important as well for seo
you can see the color contrast of
all the texts and buttons in the website
you can deactivate the whole styles of
your website so you can see really the
dom structure
just plain or you can inspect the html
so you can see a bit more and dig into
the on into the html so it is a very
complete uh tool that you can you can
install
of course i talked before about um
native the development tools in your
browser and in this case both chrome and
firefox has simulators uh you can find
the chrome developer tool simulator and
then rendering and you can simulate
vision defect deficiencies and in this
case i'm simulating a blurry vision so
you can see a bit blurry and in firefox
what i'm
simulating is a
color blindness so if you see the blue
and the pink and if i go back to the
chrome developer tools you can see that
the colors are different because i'm
simulating a color blindness so we need
to understand that red
blue and green
is not red blue and grey for everyone so
we cannot rely only on colors for
example for error messages or
login screen and then only the border of
the inputs are red well red is not
always right for everyone
good so
pretty much
those are the
tips that i had for you so again test
your code while you develop you can use
either axe or a linter while you are in
the visual in the code editor
use the browser development tools they
are very powerful
you can use cli tools in the terminal
and you can automate your accessibility
device i show you today github actions
but if you have other cicd
tool then you can include it as well
and of course do manual and simulation
test either with a screen reader or with
extension
if you want to read
more about accessibility i tend to write
pretty much only about accessibility
in my blog
i want to take advantage and and
recommend you a
course official course done by the w3c
you can find it in edx it's called
introduction to web accessibility it is
not a technical course
but it is a good introduction to start
knowing more about the importance of web
accessibility
and i want to
to leave
with a couple of sentences that i think
it summarize
the
meaning of accessibility and this one
said it's not just about disabled using
users being able to access your website
is about everyone being able to access
your website
at the beginning i said that
you there are a lot of typos impairments
permanent situational
so
we are all disabled
we don't know when it's going to be zero
percent when it's going to be 20 when
it's going to be 100
it might be that you have your kid in
one hand and you need to navigate the
website doing using the top key
you
you you
drop your computer the screen is black
you don't have a second screen you need
to buy a flight then you need to use a
screen reader
you don't have your glasses with you you
don't have your mouse with you so we
need to understand that we are not doing
accessible websites for disabled people
because
you don't know your users maybe you
heard that before you don't know who you
are building websites for
and there's one
true thing you're not building websites
or products for your company you're
building websites for humans
okay so
forget about what your company says
you're building products for other
humans to use
so since we don't know
since we don't know who
is in the other side we need to be sure
that our products are accessible for
everyone
and why i say that because accessibility
is not a feature it's never been it's
not it's not now it's not going to be
it's not a feature it's not a post
process it doesn't cost money it doesn't
cost time
it's not a feature
we need to include accessibility in not
only in our development process but in
the product design process
from the idea from ux designers pm ceo
cto everyone needs to be involved this
is not a developer responsibility to
include an alt text in an image they are
super good tools for designers for
example figma has
accessibility annotations
a product manager needs to say okay i
want this text in the button but is this
text meaningful enough because we have
what we call invisible disabilities
cognitive disability for example is is
continue is safe delete
enough for you it is because you know
the context but delete what continue to
where
those are the things that we need to
think about when we not only when we
develop because we we are maybe
transforming a design into into a
website but the designer is going to
tell you use these colors because these
colors are passing the color contrast
and maybe a pm po whoever needs to
specify the requirements say and we want
this text because this text is
meaningful enough and if not
add the context if continue is not is is
what you want in the button use an area
label to add context for those who are
using a
a
screen reader
i tend to say that what we are lacking
is education or i used to say that we
are what we are lacking is education
which is true
um i don't know
who what framework or or what are you
developing in and i don't care
everything renders in html css and
javascript the rest is just grammar
you're writing different grammar than me
but everything is html and css so we
need to educate people about the basics
but what i say now lately is we need a
cultural change
if you as developer are writing an image
is this image with alt okay i need to
include an ad
you're writing an anchor link with the
content is a is a
telephone number
okay screen reader is going to to say
three million six hundred and twenty
five thousand okay that's not good area
label call the support team okay that's
not education because you know that
images should have an alt and you know
that area label exists is a cultural
change where you say
this is not accessible i'm going to make
accessible and if we can and if we get
to that cultural change in the in the
industry because again we are well
educated we just don't have this
cultural change and if we arrive there
then we are making good products and if
we are making good products we are
making good internet and we are making
good internet
we are making good society
[Applause]
you